perfection is the enemy of progress
whatever that you want to do someone
else has already done it you don't have
to start at a very bottom so in order to
be successful yes ha work has its place
a lot of people work hard but it's not
enough the motivation watch a top ten
with belief nation what's that belief
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from having his first job at 16 working
at a local supermarket for minimum wage
to starting and failing many businesses
and then eventually becoming a
multi-millionaire by the age of 27 he's
Dan Locke and here's my take on his top
ten rules to success volume 6 also if
you want to know what Dane Locke and
others have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below after you practice
martial art you develop this natural
self confidence not cockiness but you
develop this natural self-confidence
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get attention look at Kim Kardashian
it shows you you don't need talents to
make money you just need to get it well
is she a great singer
it's your great actress what does she do
she gets attention yes and people pay
for the attention most businesses fail
write this down because they are not
getting enough attention in the
marketplace if you want to grow your
revenue you want to grow your brand you
want to grow your company you must get
attention
you must get attention attention it's a
new currency money follows attention
think of whatever products and services
in your marketplace in your industry
that are their products and services
there are maybe less quality than what
you're offering but they're selling more
how many we've seen that before yes why
because they're committed those
companies even though they have a less
quality product service they committed
to getting attention you got to get it
out there you got to push your name
because there's so much noise I hear
people but then I put on like that one
tweet you know on one Facebook pearls
how come orders don't come rolling in
guess it's one boss don't think in terms
of one not one tweaked ten tweaks a
hundred tweaks a thousand tweaks
rule number two be dedicated to mastery
I'm at the Tokyo Skytree
you see one of the things that I love
Japan about the Japanese culture is
their dedication to
mastery see the other day I was walking
down the street in Japan and I saw this
gentleman Poly's 70 80 years old and
he's running his West wrong it's
preparing the supplies and waking up
early in the morning and just getting
ready to do what he does probably been
doing it for many many decades many many
years here he has a smile on his face is
it that is absolutely incredible because
when you think about it in the North
America culture you know what I'm
talking about that we are sometimes very
impatient that we want something
immediately yeah I think we don't
dedicate enough time to master it then
we don't dedicate enough time to master
something in our lives and most people
will struggle financially you notice
they jump from one thing to another they
try a little bit their sleeve with a
little bit of this we do have that
extremely distracted and little focus on
that one thing so how do you master
anything how do you master a skill
except dedication is he in Japan it
doesn't matter if they are making
chopsticks it doesn't nagger matter if
they are running a restaurants it
doesn't matter if they're making noodles
it doesn't matter they're making shoes
chances are sometimes they've been doing
there for generations that their father
to the same thing and they're running a
small business and they don't look upon
what they do as just always a job that
I'm doing
that our man it's a Jo B no it is their
career to take pride in what they do
even making a little dessert you can see
the dedication the effort these
powerfulness
that go into it I think that's something
that I find it not just fascinating but
something very much I admire it's
something that I think we can all learn
from you have to understand that when it
comes to master it you don't get it
overnight it takes time you don't build
this overnight it takes years and years
and years of dedication that mastery
there's no shortcut rule number three
serve how can you be of service and give
back to others you see success is not
about what you get it's about what you
give and I don't just mean giving
stupidly I mean giving strategically
giving help giving back to others who
deserve your help and not everyone
deserves your help but you can find that
brilliance where it's something that you
enjoy doing non-stop it is what you are
good at what comes easy to you at the
same time it is a service of others and
that you can impact other people you
give back to others then life it's easy
life is good because you love doing it
and naturally if you are good and you
love doing it naturally you will get
good right and when you get good you'll
be able to help more people see this is
something I learned the hard way because
for the first 10 years of my business
career let's say for my 20s to my 30
years old when I'm when I'm just
building my empire I was all about me me
me me me I know what it's like it's all
about you know how can I make the most
amount of money right how can I grab all
the chips on the table there's no weight
win is only win lose and I want to win
and you're gonna lose and I did that and
I made quite a bit of money but
something was missing something wasn't
working until I learned there is no life
it's not just about yourself when you
can integrate your strengths what you're
good at and you can impact other people
life becomes much more interesting
not to mention when you make it about
others and guess what money comes to you
so easily so effortlessly rule number
four have a mentor number four and that
is having a mentor a mentor standing on
the shoulders of giants learning from
someone who's been there and done that
it's extremely critical why we invent
the wheels why not borrow someone else's
wagons instead right whatever that you
want to do someone else has already done
it you don't have to start at the very
bottom you can start at where your
mentor is gone and start right at that
level and then go from there isn't that
a much smarter way to learn instead of
going through the school of hard knocks
number five get it going you don't have
to get it right you just have have to
get it going you don't have to get it
right you just have to get it going
most entrepreneurs is what I do
they mentally masturbate too much I
don't know let me think about it I'll
get back to you let me talk no
perfection is the enemy of progress so
you know what you want article you don't
like who cares upload it you have to
create a video that you don't like who
cares upload it you what you you wrote a
blog post that you don't like who cares
treat the crap out of it there's a great
quote that love from wheat Hoffman the
founder of LinkedIn he said if you're
not embarrassed by the first version of
a product you've launched too late if
not embarrassed by the first person a
version of your product eventually rule
number six find your brilliance so in
order to be successful yes ha work has
its place a lot of people work hard but
it's not enough it's not just as part of
the equation but it's not the only
factor I believe to be successful in
life or in business you need to find
what I call your
brilliance that's right you're brilliant
what comes easy for you but it's hard
for others what comes easy for you what
are your strengths what are you
naturally good at not necessarily just
physically but it could be what skills
do you have what is easy for you because
sometimes we take it for granted what is
easy for you may not be so easy for
others you see sometimes people talk
about the concept of he's got to work on
your weaknesses I don't believe in that
I believe if you work on your weaknesses
at the end of your life you will have
guess what a lot of strong weaknesses I
believe in life it is about finding and
identifying your strengths and put your
effort to make your strengths stronger
focus on a couple of things that you are
good at and how can you make that
stronger and offer that to the
marketplace in a change of money to
render a service that's what works rule
number seven develop valuable skills
so think about desire versus skills
desires versus skills you might have the
desire to be successful and that's cool
you have the desire I am interested I
want to buy a new home I want to pay off
my debt I want to help my mom I want to
buy that new car but if you don't have
the skillset to back it up there is
nothing you have a desire but you don't
have the skills you'll always be
frustrated it's perfectly fine you can
follow up you on Instagram you follow me
on Facebook and you look at their life
and it's all cool you have the desire
but unless you have the skillsets unless
you back it up
with your skills it's not gonna work
so what skills I'm talking about I'm
talking about skills or marketing I'm
talking about skills of selling skills
are closing skills of revenue generation
how to manage your time skills of
personal self-management skills of time
management
all these excuses that you must develop
if you want to be wealthy so you have a
choice
you can have your desires and no skills
and you'll be frustrated for the rest
of your life or you have your desires
and combined with skillsets now you've
got something
now you can back it up now you create
the life that you want rule number eight
use the third door today we'll teach a
concept call the third door you see in
any situation there's always someone or
something when you can meet at some
person it opens so many possibilities
for you
I want you to imagine if you want to go
to a nightclub okay you go to a
nightclub you could line up like
everybody else right that's the first
door that you are lining up and
hopefully you dress well if you're later
you can walk in easily right if you're a
guy you got away you gotta pay you gotta
you gotta wait for the pounce if the
bouncer likes you then unless you walk
in or maybe you wait two three hours or
if you are like the VIP that you spend
the big bucks right where now you are
you get you get a VIP table you're
spending big money that's the second
door you could go in and you don't have
to wait in line like everybody else but
you're spending a lot of money now the
fourth or the third tour I'm talking
about something different where let's
say you get to be friends with the DJ
then you know it's gonna play at that
night or it's a very popular DJ and
you'd be afraid with that DJ they say a
couple weeks in advance and you get to
know the DJ now that's a third tour you
get a club without paying all these
extra money without lining up you can
kind of skip the line and then because
you find that one person that can help
you skip all the headaches they can skip
all the typical traditional way of
approaching someone so I want you think
about your business when you don't have
that resources when you don't know
somebody don't let that stop you what it
where's the third door how can you find
that person you get to meet that person
you'll open up the door possibility for
you rule number nine add value if you
want develop establish relationship with
with powerful successful people here's
what you do do not go up to them and
pitch your stuff don't try to sell them
your stuff okay you have to understand
when someone comes up to me and say oh
dear look at my product cometh in the
dark and you promote it da da da da da
you have to understand what is
to me it's like well dan you don't know
me but can you endorse me to your most
important clients and partners it's no
different if I walk up to the street and
I walk up to a beautiful woman and say
your place or mine but somehow in
business is okay so here's what you do
here's what you do here's how you follow
up here's how we do what let me give you
a tip do not give them your business
card it is not their job to follow up
with you it is your job to follow up
with them they are already successful
they have what you want why the hell
would they follow up with you you think
about it so don't give them your
business card here's what you do ask for
their contact information and once you
have that maybe a simple email and then
you follow up and here's the two
questions you ask it's two simple
questions first question is how can I
learn more from you not such pictures
how can I learn more from you and second
is my favorite what is the most
important project that you're working on
that I on my networking edit value' -
I'll say it again what is the most
important project that I or my network
can add value to don't go up to people
and say would you like to buy my stuff
but you need to business with me
write this down needy is creepy
okay needy is creepy and rule number ten
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is focus on work-life integration
so how do you achieve work/life balance
how to run a global organization be able
to travel win with Japan for twenty days
with Jenny right and also be able to
create content and impact millions of
people in the world while maintaining
sanity how do you do that well the key
question is not so much work-life
balance but work-life integration I want
to think about back then when you were a
little kid the balance swing that you
played you have two kids one on this
side one on this side and they're
playing this kind of seesaw right in
order to have momentum in order to have
fun with their game whatever they do
it's always like this
imagine the barrel and swing is
perfectly balanced perfectly steel what
would happen the thing won't be moving
you won't be having any momentum that is
exactly like life if you're perfectly
balanced you will have no momentum and
they're not going anywhere what you need
to do is you know think about what is
important for me what's my priority
because you cannot achieve greatness
remember Greek success requires great
effort anything that requires great
effort
you cannot say oh I'm gonna have a
perfect body I'm gonna have a perfect
family life I'm gonna have a lot of free
time and I want to build something great
it doesn't work that way
something has to give you have to
sacrifice there's a pay price to action
what are you willing to give up to get
what you want see one of the key
questions that I ask myself is when I
was getting started
what is the one goal that if I
complicate would get me everything else
would give me all the other goals and I
knew I had to focus on money first
because when I get money out of the way
I can focus on what's important in my
life
now nothing be a workaholic and I'm not
talking about money's everything I'm
talking about I need to sacrifice so my
other priorities what is that one thing
if I complet that everything else would
work
and I pick business because I knew when
I get the money out of the way man I
made my fu money everything would work
much easier then you can have more
balance it's not so much balance so even
when I'm traveling guess what I'm making
a video for you right with my team it's
not balance its work-life integration
how do you integrate what you do into
your daily life now imagine you're a
golfer someone asked you how do you
balance golf with your family life you
would say well what are you talking
about I'm a golfer I play as much golf
as possible and I've loved golf things
in my life because I am a golfer that's
exactly what I'm talking about
when you are an entrepreneur when your
go getter when you are an influencer
that is work-life integration what you
do your life and your work they are very
blurry that line is very very blurry and
that's exactly what I'm talking about so
forget this work-life balance both focus
on work-life integration how to
integrate your life how to integrate
with your work how to integrate all of
that with what you do that's the secret
to having that work-life balance
now I've got a really special bonus tip
from Dan on how to surround yourself
with greatness that I think you're
really gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to taking action
in your life or business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one what does work-life
integration look like for you number two
how can you add value to your customers
life today enema 3 what's a third door
solution to a problem you're facing
right now
if you go into a room and you're the
smartest person in that room we've got a
problem you want to be the poorest
person in the circle that you hang out
with that's only where you grow you want
to group you want to hang out with
people who pull you up and not drag you
down maybe they're your family and
friends but if they drag you down you
don't want to spend time with them you
cannot afford to spend time with them hi
this is Dan Locke if you're a fan of
Evans work if you want to know exactly
how to model my success I want to invite
you to join me for a special online
training all you have to do is click on
a link below you can join me for
absolutely no charge so click on link
below and I will see you in class
if you want more Dane lock check at the
top fifty rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
the more try to chase the money I want
to make the money want to make the money
you can see these people they're so
desperate they don't make money you
don't make money if your life stinks is
your fault